Alemania es un país famoso en el mundo enteroporque es donde se han inventado todas las perversiones...
que no se habían inventado previamente en Japón.
Hablamos del lugar donde ha nacido Rammstein,
la cultura nudista y los coches de marca BMW.
Sin embargo, Alemania tiene algo aún más
importante que todo eso.
Hablamos de la auténtica fábrica del mundo.
Tal cual como lo oís.
Y sí, ya sé lo que estáis pensando ¿No
sé supone que es China el país donde se
fabrican las televisiones, los móviles y prácticamente todo lo que
compramos hoy en día?
¡Pues no es del todo cierto!
Por supuesto que China es el país lidera el ranking de
exportaciones.
Pero también necesitan importar un montón
de productos del extranjero.
Alemania, sin embargo, vende mucho más de
lo que compra.
Es más 1 de cada 10 productos que se venden en el mundo, está
hecho en este país que tiene 15 veces menos población que China.
Por supuesto, todos conocemos las grandes
empresas de automóviles como BMW,  Audi o VOLKSWAGEN…
¡Pero hay mucho, muchísimo más!
¿Todavía no me creéis? Pues mirad vuestro teléfono móvil.
Sí, ya sé que en la etiqueta pone que está
“ENSAMBLADO EN LA REPÚBLICA POPULAR DE
CHINA”.
Pero si abrís la carcasa, os encontraréis
un montón de microchips ¿Verdad?
Pues, por ejemplo, el componente que hace
que la pantalla rote cuando movemos el
teléfono estará hecho, seguramente, por
una empresa alemana que se llama BOSCH SENSORTECH
¡Pero no sólo eso!
Muchos de los robots que utilizan en las fábricas
chinas para ensamblar los distintos materiales
también están fabricados por trabajadores
alemanes.
En otras palabras, Alemania es el lugar donde
se fabrican las cosas que van dentro de las cosas que fabrican otros.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Cómo es esto posible?
¿No se supone que las fábricas se construyen
en lugares con mano de obra barata?
¿Cómo es posible que Alemania, con unos
sueldos relativamente altos, sea una semejante
potencia industrial?
Hoy, vamos a responder a esta pregunta pero
antes… vamos a ver un poco de historia.
ORDOLIBERALISMO
Tras la II Guerra Mundial, toda Europa estaba
destruida por los bombardeos.
Así que Países como Italia,
Francia o la Alemania Occidental, que era
la parte de Alemania que tenía un sistema capitalista,
recibieron una inyección de miles de millones
de dólares de parte de su amigo el tío Sam
¡Pero esperad un momento porque cada uno de estos países utilizó
ese dinero de formas muy distintas!
En Francia, tenían como presidente a este
señor que véis aquí, el General Charles de Gaulle.
De Gaulle venía del ejército y no era muy amigo de
las empresas y la competencia.
Su doctrina política, el llamado
DIRIGISMO, consistía en nacionalizar todas
las grandes empresas y dirigir toda la economía del país como si fuera un ejército.
En Alemania Occidental eligieron un camino
totalmente distinto.
Tanto el canciller KONRAD ADENAUER como
su ministro de finanzas, LUDWIG ERHART, llevaban
años teorizando sobre un sistema económico distinto.
Un sistema que combinaba la competencia del libre
mercado con la red de seguridad del estado.
A este sistema le pusieron un nombre horrendo
Lo llamaron ORDOLIBERALISMO o Economía SOCIAL
DE MERCADO.
“La competición es el mejor medio para
asegurar la prosperidad” –Ludwig Erhart
En otras palabras. Mientras de Gaulle centralizó toda la economía
en el Gobierno de París, Konrad Adenauer
diseñó un sistema donde el estado
pone las condiciones y los demás actores
sociales toman sus propias decisiones.
Eso explica por qué en Alemania son tan importantes
los sindicatos, los gobiernos
regionales y, por supuesto, las empresas.
Y ahora os preguntaréis ¿Cuáles son las
claves de este sistema?
¿Realmente ha funcionado? Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
ESTABILIDAD MONETARIA
Estoy seguro de que todos habéis escuchado
a algún economista decir que devaluar la
moneda es bueno para mejorar las exportaciones ¿Verdad?
Por ejemplo, imaginad que tenemos una fábrica de zapatos en México y
queremos vender un par de zapatos en EEUU por 2000 pesos.
En este momento en el que hacemos el vídeo,
estos 2000 pesos equivalen a unos 110 dólares ¡Pero imaginad que, de repente, el Banco Central de México
decide imprimir más billetes y, por tanto,
devaluar el peso.
De un día para otro, ese par de zapatos valdría, por ejemplo 90 dólares.
Es decir, que sería mucho más fácil de
vender en el extranjero.
Esta es la teoría que sostienen casi todos
los gobiernos de hoy en día.
Sin embargo, el Gobierno Alemán hizo todo lo contrario.
Durante toda la segunda mitad del siglo XX, el MARCO ALEMÁN se convirtió en una
de las divisas más estables del mundo.
Y os preguntaréis… ¿Cómo es posible que
Alemania pudiera exportar tanto si sus productos
no eran tan baratos?
Pues bien, vamos a volver al ejemplo de los
zapatos.
He buscado por internet y he encontrado una empresa en el Norte de Alemania que se llama DESMA.
Se trata de una PYME con poco más de 200
trabajadores.
Empezaron justo después de la guerra, en
1946, y se especializaron en la fabricación de máquinas para fabricar zapatos.
Para eso, lógicamente, necesitaron importar
un montón de máquinas, muchas de las cuales
estaban en Estados Unidos.
Gracias a tener una moneda estable, el precio
de importar estas máquinas era
relativamente barato y hasta pudieron invertir
en alquilar una nave industrial. A fin de cuentas, como
los alquileres no iban a subir, era muy sencillo
calcular si podían permitirse todos estos gastos año tras año.
¡No sólo eso!
Como las empresas alemanas no podían competir
en precio, a DESMA no le quedó otro  que innovar remedio
En 1960, invirtieron en el desarrollo de tecnologías
punteras para poder hacer máquinas que
fabricaran suelas de goma.
Así que, 10 años más tarde, DESMA se convirtió
en el líder mundial de
fabricación de máquinas que hacen suelas
de PVC.
Muy probablemente, la suela de los zapatos
que lleváis
ahora mismo esté fabricada por una máquina
DESMA.
Esta empresa, que sólo tiene 220 trabajadores,
vende a todo el mundo, incluido China.
Y este sólo un ejemplo más de las miles
de pequeñas y medianas empresas, las llamadas
MITTELSTAND, que han hecho rica a Alemania.
“El éxito de las MITTELSTANDs ha atraído
miradas de admiración del resto de Europa”
¡Y sí!
Ya sé que, en el año 2002, los alemanes
abandonaron el marco y empezaron a utilizar el EURO.
Pero pensadlo bien, mientras otros países como
España venían de utilizar monedas mucho más inestables,
Alemania llevaba décadas de ventaja.
¡Pero esperad un momento por que hay otras
razones que explican este éxito del modelo alemán!
Vamos a verlas.
EL SISTEMA EDUCATIVO
Ya sé lo que me vais a decir.
Fonseca, Alemania no es famosa por su sistema
educativo.
Si miráis el informe PISA, por ejemplo, Alemania no está
ni en los 10 primeros puestos.
Sin embargo, los estudiantes
alemanes encuentran trabajo nada más terminan
los estudios.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Por qué?
La respuesta está en su sistema de formación
profesional.
Imaginad que estudiáis en un instituto alemán
y no queréis ir a la universidad.
Así que os metéis a hacer un curso de formación
profesional para ser electricista, por ejemplo.
Pues bien, desde el primer día que hacéis
ese curso, ya estáis trabajando para
una empresa que tiene un convenio con el colegio.
De lunes a miércoles vais a clase y de jueves
a viernes vais al taller.
En ese taller os van a formar los propios
trabajadores y la empresa o va a pagar un pequeño sueldo.
Lógicamente, estamos hablando de poco dinero:
unos 300 o 500 euros al mes
¡Ojo! Que esto es muy importante.
El hecho de que paguen a los estudiantes significa
que les tienen que sacar partido
porque si no, pierden ese dinero.
Así que la empresa es la más interesada
en que los alumnos trabajen y aprenden.
Y, creedme, sé de lo que estoy hablando porque
yo estudié Formación Profesional en España.
En España, los estudiantes de FP van al colegio durante un
curso y medio.
Y sólo es en los últimos tres meses cuando
hacen prácticas en la empresa.
Esas empresas tienen prohibido por ley pagar
a los alumnos ¿Qué ocurre?
Que no tienen ningún incentivo para poner
a trabajar a los estudiantes.
Y me pasé tres meses de mi vida
en una oficina, sentado en una silla, mientras
jugaba a la serpiente con el teléfono móvil.
En el caso de Alemania es totalmente distinto.
Durante dos años, los estudiantes han estado
en un entorno profesional real.
Y de hecho, muchos de ellos se quedan en las
empresas donde han hecho las prácticas.
Y, por supuesto, las empresas alemanas tienen
trabajadores bien formados.
Pero… ya que hablamos de los trabajadores,
hay otra pieza clave en el sistema alemán.
LOS SINDICATOS ALEMANES
En otros países como Francia, casi toda la
legislación laboral se redacta en el parlamento.
En Alemania no es así.
Para que os hagáis una idea, hasta el año
2015, los alemanes ni siquiera tenían un salario
mínimo estipulado por el estado.
Todos los sueldos se negocian entre los sindicatos
y las empresas.
En este país, los sindicatos son importantísimos.
De hecho, las grandes empresas como AUDI o
BMW, que
tienen más de 2000 trabajadores, están obligadas
a tener a los delegados sindicales en el consejo
de
administración.
Al mismo nivel que los accionistas.
Por ejemplo, una empresa como SIEMENS tiene
a 10
representantes de la junta de accionistas
y, por ley, también tiene que tener a otros
10 representantes
de los trabajadores.
¡Quedaos con esto por que es muy importante!
En España, por ejemplo, una empresa tan grande
como
TELEFÓNICA no tiene delegados sindicales
en el consejo de administración.
Los representantes de los
trabajadores sólo pueden participar en un
órgano aparte que es el consejo de empresa.
Y sólo pueden
negociar sueldos y condiciones laborales.
Sin embargo en Alemania, los sindicatos están
presentes en todas las decisiones de la empresa.
Si, por
ejemplo, SIEMENS quisiera abrir una nueva
fábrica o sacar una nueva línea de productos
tendría que
consultarlo con los accionistas y con los
trabajadores.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Y esto qué ventajas
tiene para las empresas alemanas?
Normalmente, damos por hecho que
los sindicatos y las empresas son enemigos
naturales ¿Verdad?
¡Pues no tiene por qué!
Gracias a esta política laboral, los trabajadores
de SIEMENS o BMW saben, en todo momento si la empresa está ganando o perdiendo dinero.
Y, por supuesto, cuando las cosas van mal,
pueden negociar una reducción
temporal de horas de trabajo, por ejemplo,
en lugar de hacer despidos.
“Open recortará las horas de trabajo en
sus fábricas alemanas”
Es decir, que gracias a los sindicatos y su
poder de negociación, las empresas alemanas
no tuvieron que
hacer despidos masivos durante la crisis financiera
de 2008.
Esto es bueno para los trabajadores pero
también es bueno para las empresas, que pueden
aguantar mejor las situaciones de vacas flacas.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque ya sé lo
que estáis pensando!
Que los sindicatos alemanes están
conchabados con los empresarios para explotar
a los trabajadores ¿Verdad?
Pues lo cierto es que no.
De hecho, el salario medio en Alemania supera
los 3400 dólares al mes.
Muy por encima del de España.
Y con un coste de vida muy parecido.
Para que os hagáis una idea, Berlín tiene
unos precios muy similares a Madrid.
Y sin embargo, pese a tener unos salarios
tan altos, Alemania es el tercer país que
más exporta del mundo.
Y ahora la pregunta es… ¿Creéis que vuestro
país podría mejorar si imitara el modelo alemán?
¿O tal vez
pensáis que es imposible implementar estas
políticas en otros lugares?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta alemán?
Mientras tanto, si queréis conocer el modelo
económico de Francia, podéis hacer click
en este otro vídeo.
Y por cierto, tengo que darle las gracias
a ANTONIO AVÍS, que fue delegado sindical en Cáceres, por
haberme ayudado a entender mejor cómo funcionan
los sindicatos en España.
Y como siempre, no olvidéis que sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas así que  suscribíos al canal para
no perderos ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo.
Un abrazo y hasta pronto.